where we left off in the last video we
were able to figure out the coordinates
of all of the vertices for this face
right here of the tetrahedron and so now
we can use those coordinates to figure
out the coordinates of the centre of
that face which is also one of the
vertices of the smaller tetrahedron and
when we figure out that coordinate then
we could figure out the distance between
that point and that point or between
this point and this point and that will
give us the length of one of the sides
of the small tetrahedron and then we can
compare that to the length of the large
tetrahedron and get this ratio right
over here so let's get the coordinates
of that point or at this point right
over here let's get the coordinates of
this thing and to do that we just have
to take the average of the x y&z
coordinates of the fate of the vertices
of the face now for X you can see
hopefully maybe you see that this is
sitting on the Y z axis actually let me
draw the z court the z axis here just
for just for visualization so Z could go
up like that and then this would be the
negative the negative Z direction would
be going down like that so this is
clearly lying on the zy plane but even
if you didn't see that you could just
you could just average the X you could
just average the X points here so we
have negative 1 plus 1 plus 0 over 3
which is going to be 0 over 3 and then
you could average the Y points 0 plus 0
0 plus 0 plus square root of 3 over 3
square root of 3 over 3 all of that over
3 and then you can average the Z points
let me do it in a different color
average the Z 0 plus 0 0 plus 0 plus 2
square roots of 2 over the square root
of 3 all of that over all of that over 3
now this first coordinate right over
here clearly just 0 second coordinate
over here square is going to be the
square root of this is the square root
of 3 over 3 so it's hard to read square
root of 3 over 3 divided by 3 so it's
the square root of 3 over 9 and then we
have to
two square root of two over the square
root of three divided by three so it's
going to be two times the square root of
two over three times the square root of
three this right here are the
coordinates for the center of this face
this coordinate right over here now
using that we can now find the distance
between that point and that point we
already know that this points
coordinates we already know the center
of the base we already know that right
over here so let's figure out let's
figure out this distance or this
distance the length of this side of the
smaller tetrahedron so let's write it
let me do it over here the length of the
side of a smaller tetrahedron squared is
going to be our difference in X value
squared so this has an x value of zero
this has an x value of zero so zero
minus zero squared plus the difference
in Y values square root of three over
nine minus square root of 3 over 3 minus
square root of 3 over 3 just we have a
common denominator that's the same thing
as three square roots of three over nine
I just wanted to rewrite it this way so
that I have a common denominator squared
plus plus two square roots of two it's
getting messy because I'm plus two
square roots of 2 over 3 square roots of
three - this guy is Z coordinate well
this guy was on the XY plane so it's
minus zero minus zero squared so this is
going to be equal to let me write it
here let me scroll to the left a little
bit so I have some space so we have a
length of the small of the small
tetrahedron squared is going to be equal
to well this is just going to be zero
this right here is negative two times
the square root of 3 over 9 squared so
negative 2 times the square root of 3
over 9 squared is 4 times 3 right
negative 2 times square root of 3
squared is going to be 4 times 3 over 9
squared over 81 over 81 so we did that
part right over here right yeah we had
negative 2 times square root of 3 over 9
you square that you get this over here
so that turns into that and then this
term right over here this is just going
- root 2 over 3 root 3 squared so it's
going to be plus so this is going to be
4 times 2 over 9 times over 9 times 3 or
another way of saying it this is going
to be equal to let's see what the
numerator denominator are divisible by 3
so this is the same thing as 4 over 27
so this first term is 4 over 27 plus we
have over here 4 times 2 is 8 over 27
which is equal 2 which is the same thing
as 12 over 27 you divide the numerator
and the denominator by 3 this is equal
to 4 4 over 9 so the length of the small
side squared the length of a small side
squared is equal to 4 over 9
you take the principal root on both
sides positive square root we only care
about positive values because we're
talking about distances so the length of
one side is going to be equal to the
square root of that which is going to be
2 over 3 so this distance right here or
this length right here is going to be
2/3 or this length right here is going
to be 2/3 so what's the ratio of a
length of a big side to the length of a
small side so the length of a big side
we already figured out the length of the
big side is 2 this thing is 2 what's the
length of a small side well based on all
the math we just did it is 2/3 it is 2/3
now before we even cube it we can divide
the numerator and the denominator by 2
actually well yeah we can take the new
divide the numerator and the denominator
by 2 so this becomes 1/2 1/3 which is +
1 / 1/3 is the same thing as 3 so 3
cubed is 27
this is or I can write it as 27 - 1
since we want to write it as a ratio so
when you simplify all this you get 20
you really will just get 27 but if you
want to express it as a ratio it is 27
to 1 the volume of the big big
tetrahedron - the volume of the small so
that ratio is M over N this is equal to
M over N
M and n are relatively prime positive
integers these are definitely relatively
prime their only common factor is one
find M plus n so 27 plus 1 is 28 so our
answer is 28